La volta a Monapeu, dia 269, crec. No ho sé.
Quina nit més horrible. De les pitjors nits de tot el viatge, tu.
Aquesta obra està 24 hores.
Tota la nit han estat passant camions.
Com aquest d'ara. Tota la nit. Tota la nit.
Però no tota la nit vull dir fins a les 12. No, no, tota la nit vull dir...
Tota la nit, fins ara. No en stop. Pum, pum, pum. Clar, no he dormit res.
Bé, no sé si he dormit alguna cosa. Diria que no.
A més, no he parat de mucar-me.
Tinc una de mocs. Tinc una de mocs com si estigués encostipat.
Mira, tot això són paper de vàter. Aquí a Tajikistan el paper de vàter era així.
Paper de vàter d'anar-me sonant.
Com la primera setmana de la muntamonapeu, que estava encostipat, doncs igual.
I això de què és? D'agafar un encostipat?
No sé si és de l'encostipat o de...
O de la pols.
Perquè la pols que vaig respirant se m'ha ficat entre els pulmons.
Jo crec que el cos la vol treure, no?
No ho sé, és una teoria que tinc.
Però, bueno, bueno.
Fatal, eh?
Fatal. És tard, són les 8.33.
Per tant, avui, entre pitos i flautes, caminaré poc i faré el que pugui.
Està.
D'acord, ara estic en aquest pont i toca pujar per aquestes zigazagues d'aquí, pum, pum, pum,
fins allà dalt i després seguir caminant fins a Hoburabot Pass, a 3.200 i pico metres sobre el nivell del mar.
Llavors, des d'aquí fins al pas són 1.100 i pico de descenari positiu en 17 quilòmetres.
Pujada sostinguda, però tampoc dramàtica.
Reto, paciència, a poc a poc, anar descansant.
Puc caminar, no és que no pugui caminar, però, bé, estic més cansat de l'habitual, evidentment.
Porto una hora de camí, ja estic a dalt de les zigazagues.
Aquest era el lloc de campada que hagués agafat si no hagués estat amb els italians tantes hores.
Només porto una hora, per tant, hagués pogut arribar fins aquí i, home, menys pols, menys soroll, millors vistes, buah,
hagués estat molt millor.
Porto gairebé dues hores, són les 11 menys quart, parada per menjar alguna cosa i descansar aquí a una font
i uns quants ciclistes aquí, que, bueno, doncs com sempre he estat xerrant amb ells, explicant el que estic fent,
molt bé, tu, ciclistes, d'aquests, per cert, ells em van passar a mi, llavors en algun moment jo els he passat i ara m'han tornat a passar avui.
Però, bueno, a la que passem el pas, o sigui, a la pujada la diferència de velocitat entre un ciclista i jo no és tanta,
especialment un ciclista que porta les alfòsies plenes i tal, ells van més ràpid, però no gaire més.
Però, clar, la baixada és quan la diferència és, potser ells, en una hora, fan el que jo podria fer en un dia,
o més, saps?, si van a 50-60 km per hora, jo, ni de conya, però, bueno, tu, està bé, està bé tenir aquesta companyia de tant en quant.
Res, 15-20 minuts des del lloc on he parat, ara tinc un núvol, cosa rara, eh?, mireu, abans he assenyalat el que pensava que era el pas,
té tota la pinta de ser allò, saps?, té tota la pinta, però crec que no és, crec que no és, sempre està bé tenir l'objectiu a la vista, no?,
però no, diria que en aquest cas...
No, és, bueno, ja, ja ho veurem, és igual.
Estem a la meitat, això sí, he fet 600 metres de desnivell positiu, queden uns altres 600.
Vaig bé, tu.
Bona nit.
Just ara, arribo als 3.000 metres sobre el nivell del mar, i queden 250 metres de desnivell positiu.
Mira, primer cotxe que passa en hores, en hores. I què més?
I queden 4,5 km en pla.
I aquí hi ha això, Camarte com a refugi al mar.
i hi ha uns ciclistes també.
A veure si puc descansar un rato a dintre.
Hello!
Is it open?
Yes.
Ok.
Perfect.
Les vistes brutals, eh, des d'aquí.
Ostres, tu!
A veure, què tal això?
Uah, està fet caldo. Bueno, no tant.
És... res, és això. Hi ha una ximaneia.
Bueno, doncs mira, s'entraré aquí, posaré el cul aquí contra la paret i pararé una estona.
Dues menys deu.
Mireu el paisatge.
Brutal, però estic fet caldo, eh. Des que he ressortit del refugi, que es veu allà.
Bajona, eh.
M'està costant moltíssim, eh.
Últim puix.
Últims dos quilòmetres i mig.
Després hi ha baixada.
Baixada durant tres dies.
Ja està.
Les vistes a l'altra banda, tu.
Bueno.
Tres.
Dos.
Un.
Hovorabot Pass.
3.252,8 metres segons la parada d'aquest autobús.
Una parada d'autobús.
A 3.252 metres.
Sobre el nivell del mar.
Brutal.
Ostres, ha sigut duríssim, eh.
Ha sigut duríssim, avui, eh.
Però ho he aconseguit.
A veure.
Fa poc vent.
Observacions que volia fer.
Ara he pujat, per tant, estic...
El cos està calent d'haver pujat, tal, d'haver caminat, però no fa fred.
Si ara parés i no em posés res...
A veure.
Si ara parés i no em posés res sobre faria fred.
Això m'interessa a mi, pel futur, perquè quan arribi el pamir, que bueno, que tampoc
necessito tanta, tanta roba, de moment.
Potser en un futur, en unes setmanes baixen les tempestures, no?, però el dia d'avui, estem
bé.
Estem bé.
Val.
I les vistes a l'altra banda, doncs això.
Muntanyes més escarpades.
Alguna mica de neu.
Brutal.
Brutal, bueno, ara toca baixar. Primer pararé una estona, aquí a la parada de bus.
Oh, som-hi, som-hi, som-hi.
Descans fet, he estat parlant amb els ciclistes aquests, que són dos portuguesos,
i són youtubers també, tenen un, segons ell, petit canal de YouTube.
Bueno, doncs, baixada, m'han dit, ens veiem a la propera ciutat, no sé com es deia,
i jo, home, no crec, perquè està a 40 km, que això per ells pot ser una, dues hores, si van lents,
i per mi, un dia setze.
M'ha vingut un moment de, no sé com explicar-ho, d'emoció,
de dir, uau, és que mira on estic, és que estic al mig del no-res de Taxiquistà,
una carretera que baixa vertiginosament, una vall brutal,
però estic fet caldo, això sí, ara he parat vint minuts assegut i...
Uah, horrible, horrible, bueno, tu, com a mínim ho estic aconseguint, saps?,
porto, mira, a veure, us ho dic, setze cinquanta, porto vint-i-vuit quilòmetres i mig,
està molt bé, traient en compte el meu estat.
No gravaré mai, saps?, el que resta de la tarda, fins a trobar el lloc de campar.
Sis i mitja, el lloc no he assenyalat així, encara queden quatre quilòmetres,
però allà on hi ha els camions aquells, hi havia dos camioners que m'han donat,
per cert, un parell de dies que ja he menjat per sopar,
i hi ha una font, una font, està bé perquè puc treure aigua.
No és que ane a dormir allà, però igualment no dormiré allà,
he trobat aquest lloc al costat de la carretera,
a veure, és poc pla, eh?, és poc pla, però crec que ho puc apanyar,
puc apanyar si fico coses sota el matalàs per acabar d'igualar-ho i tal.
Sí, parir quatre quilòmetres més, podria fer-ho, eh?, però ja em destrueixen.
Bueno, a veure si puc acampar, ho intento.
36 quilòmetres i pico, 1.200 i pico de nivell positiu,
zero euros, cap refresc, cap cafè, he parlat amb, doncs, uns sis ciclistes o així, més o menys.
Sí, sí, sí. I com ho he fet per sonar-me tot el dia? Tenia tot el dia mocs.
Doncs no, no anava fent servir de pes, sinó feia com els futbolistes que fan així,
i sortia, sortia com una font, eh?, com una font.
Bueno, jo crec que això em durarà uns quants dies, eh?
No crec que sigui de la pols, no ho sé, no ho sé, però uns quants dies em durarà.
Bueno, estic content per haver caminat els 35 mínims, estic content.
Llavors, demà arribo a una ciutat, bueno, poble gran, que té hotels, té restaurants i tal.
Són només, crec que, 16 quilòmetres, no és gaire,
i aquesta ciutat, aquest poble, està a la frontera amb l'Afganistan.
Atenció, eh?
Bona nit.